hello world okay so the other day
someone I know was talking about Billy
Bush from Entertainment Tonight and he
was like I swear to god every time I see
that guy just need to punch him in the
face and then he asked me he's like
seriously isn't it that one celebrity
that you just seen you're like yarn just
need to punch him in the face and like
any decent human being I was like yeah
but to be honest I really had to think
about that you know that's right we just
passed the new health care reform law
the nation's divided there's war
throughout the world still and the thing
that perplexes me the most is but some
are too obvious you know like Michael
Bay for transformers to George Lucas for
the past 15 years but this had to be it
this had to make a statement honestly
speaking I'd probably punched Chuck
Norris it's not because I hate him it's
because I'd be the guy who punched Chuck
Norris and lived if I'd live I didn't
really think about the fact that I'd
probably vaporize from the impact of his
beard on my fist it'd just be like hey
Chuck hmm or the very notion that a mere
mortal would even punch Chuck Norris
would cause a paradox that would unravel
the fabric of the universe as we know it
and blink existence out of being in fact
me even mentioning it on this video
would cause the hand of Chuck Norris to
come down from the realm on Norris and
change the course of this video as we
know it or completely stop this video
from ever being fit
so for my money I'd have to say I'd
punch Kanye what you act like I was
gonna say something different well he
hurt I feel like we've talked about this
before but let's face it Kanye is a
douche and I don't even use that term
too loosely actually I do he has proven
time and time again that he is an
absolute dick and he will always be an
absolute dick mine has gotta be Kanye
with a big smile on my face so who is
your celebrity I don't try to say you've
never thought about it because
everybody's thought about it you can
take the biggest piece loving activists
on the planet and they'll just be like
no I don't do that I love everything I
love everything about people people are
great at don't push them are great you
said that Chris Brown right in the sack
so come on be honest who deserves your
wrath use the comment section below and
just blow that up and if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more just click on the link in the
sidebar to see more and yeah maybe
subscribe you know